most scream fans already know about how
scream 2022 paid tribute to wes craven
the director of screams 1-4 by naming a
character after him having a house party
dedicated to that character after his
death and repeating the words for wes as
the first thing we see in the end
credits what you might not have noticed
was the hidden meaning behind wes's
phone number the 707 is just the area
code for the part of northern california
where woodsboro would be located and all
of the woodsboro characters have this
area code but 1939 refers to the year
that wes craven was born we actually see
craven's birthday come up again later
during the youtube video about stab 2021
the channel's subscriber count is 821
939 which could be read as eight to
1939. under the american date format of
month day year this represents august 2
1939 the day wes craven was born this
page contains a lot of other easter eggs
including other hidden dates in the
numbers to learn about many classic
cameos secrets on tattoos and meanings
behind names on cell phones stick around
to the end of this video
welcome to things you missed when i
heard there was going to be a new screen
movie i was hoping the franchise would
come back to tackle the phenomenon of
prequels like halloween 2018 jurassic
world and candyman 2021 then i started
watching scream 2022 and realized oh
yeah screeform already was a requel also
i generally don't really like prequels
but what i do like about them is that
they're basically eastern as what do i
mean by that a nest is somewhere where
you might find a lot of eggs in this
case easter eggs as in the hidden
secrets found in contemporary media one
of my favorite things to analyze on
things you missed so let's get in to the
things you missed
[Music]
each entry in the screen franchise
serves as a satire of the horror genre
and sometimes of media franchises as a
whole as you are very aware of if you've
seen my previous videos on scream scream
2 scream 3 and scree form there were a
few franchises that they'd like to use
as a blueprint of sorts first there's
halloween the movie shown in the first
screen which serves as an example of
horror movie rules then there's star
wars which was most heavily discussed in
scream 3 when the characters were trying
to figure out the rules for trilogies
finally there's scream which also exists
in universe where it's known as the stab
franchise so many things that happen in
scream 2022 from bigger plot points to
little moments are callbacks to things
that have happened in the scream
franchise which is also fitting for a
requel because these movies often share
the concept of it's happening again so
for the third time in franchise history
it starts with a phone ringing then a
female picking it up and speaking to an
anonymous caller then she starts playing
with a knife block and then she gets
attacked by ghostface and she kicks her
attacker in an attempt to escape then in
a parallel to scream one a group of
friends discusses the attack the next
day while sitting outside of
woodsborough high school while eating
grapes we find out boyfriend and
girlfriend chad and liv aren't sleeping
together like sydney and billy in scream
and an announcement from the high school
principal cancels classes just like in
screen but did you notice who the new
principal was
attention panthers
according to executive producer chad
villella in this interview with bloody
disgusting that was a voice cameo from
drew barrymore who is known for playing
casey becker in the original screen
there are many other voice cameos
present in the movie most of them can be
heard during amber's party the first
comes from matthew lillard who played
stew in scream
fitting considering that this is stu's
old house several cameo voices overlap
when the guests make a toast to the
character wes
the article states that many people who
knew wes craven contributed voices for
this line including three scream actors
henry winkler who played principal
hembry adam brody who played officer
haas in spree form and hayden panettiere
who played kirby co-director tyler
gillette added that jamie kennedy who
played randy in the original scream
trilogy contributed this line
which he actually says right while his
character is delivering his lines in
stab which is playing on the tv where we
can see another cameo co-director matt
bettinelli open revealed that he plays
the on-screen michael myers in the movie
within the movie within the movie maybe
we should stop calling it scream and
start calling it trek because this thing
has got layers speaking of halloween
there's also a reference to its director
my name is samantha carpenter this is an
homage to halloween director john
carpenter or possibly wes carpenter duck
others said you're starting to sound
like some west carpenter flick or
something the new directors for scream
2022 went a little bit crazy with
references to wes craven's body of work
starting with sydney prescott's address
cindy prescott and she lived on hell
although it was mentioned in the
original script i don't think that sid's
street address was ever brought up in
the first movie but elm is a reference
to elm street from west craven's famous
franchise and nightmare on elm street we
actually see the elm street intersection
later when sam and richie roll into town
then when we're reintroduced to dewey
you can see his list of cell phone
contacts if you pause at the right
moment one of his contacts is christy
which is probably a reference to christy
parker from a nightmare on elm street
three and four christie is played by
patricia arquette the real life sister
of dewey's actor david r katz also of
note in dewey's list of contacts is b
miska which is a nod to brad miska the
owner of horror movie news website
bloody disgusting which may explain why
they have all these exclusive interviews
with the directors and producers which i
keep referencing during the youtube
scene later on the related videos panel
also suggests an upload from the bloody
disgusting channel another exclusive
interview but we'll get to that later
under bmiska keeping up with the theme
of internet horror personalities is mr
morris that's me zack morris you might
be thinking no that's just the father of
olivia morris from scree form but no she
doesn't have a father your mom home
boyfriend
so it must be talking about me if
deadmeat gets to be in it i get to be in
it too damn it another one of dewey's
contacts is judy which is probably just
a judy hicks his old deputy at the
police station i was thinking it's kind
of a shame that he never got with her
after he split up with gail but who
knows maybe he actually did actually now
that i think about it she must have
already had a kid by the time she was
hitting on dewey in scary form so that's
weird we actually see her list of
contacts too and you can spot more wes
craven related homages tina g represents
tina gray from the original nightmare on
elm street leroy is a character from
craven's 1991 film the people under the
stairs nancy t of course is nancy
thompson the main girl from a nightmare
on elm street b adams is brandon adams
the actor who played fool in the people
under the stairs under her son there are
three deputies listed deputy vincent and
deputy farney are actual characters in
the movie deputy keith is not i'm
guessing this is a crew reference easter
egg because the movie's production
designer is named chad keith for all the
west craven related easter eggs it seems
like there's only one easter egg related
to kevin williamson the screenwriter of
screams one two and four it comes when
tara is in the hospital watching an
episode of dawson's creek this is season
1 episode 11 of the scare which was
written by williamson and the episode
itself is kind of a spoof of the
original screen like i said there are a
lot of layers to this we're not done
with the west craven easter eggs though
i'll be continuing to analyze those and
richie's big slip up that would have
given him away as the killer if only his
girlfriend had noticed
[Music]
throughout the movie we see a couple of
memorials to pass characters dewey has a
box dedicated to his sister tatum and
martha has a home theater dedicated to
her brother randy on the mantle there's
also a photo of a movie theater marquee
with three movies playing a nightmare on
elm street the hills have eyes and last
house on the left all wes craven
directed films sam carpenter is
essentially the new sydney prescott in
this movie much like sydney's father in
the original we learned sam's mom is out
of town both of their mothers are
cheaters both characters have some
psychological issues caused by billy
loomis sydney because billy killed her
father and sam because billy is her real
father throughout the series i've
discussed how sydney shares similarities
with halloween's protagonist lori strode
sam takes after her as well lori was a
babysitter in the original halloween and
it turns out that sam has some
experience in child care as well these
are chad and mindy the twins and wes i
used to babysit them all the first
victim to die this time around is vince
who we eventually learn to be
stewmacher's nephew in a request
everyone has to have some dumb reason to
be related to legacy characters there's
also a little clue about this in the
opening scene where tara looks up the
cast of the original stab on her phone
there's a new addition here a cast
member who wasn't specified back in
scream 2 and that is vince vaughn
playing the role of stu mocker so the
names vince and stu are kind of linked
from the very beginning there's also a
detail on the hood of vince's car not
only a movie detail but like an actual
car detail the words six-pack are
written there perhaps a hint that we'll
be seeing a sixth movie also this guy
parked in front of him is parked in
front of a fire hydrant come on man the
cops are right there vince also has a
jason tattoo this is probably a red
herring making the audience think that
he might be the killer considering the
line that richie said earlier
and i got to make sure we don't get
sliced up by some lunatic who saw friday
the 13th and thought you know what that
jason guy he's got some pretty solid
ideas of course vince ends up being a
victim not a killer during his death
scene we hear the song red right hand
which appeared in every screen movie
besides free form so it's good to see it
back on rotation here ghostface actually
takes out vince with his own switchblade
not the usual ghostface knife i'm
guessing this is just another red
herring though to make it look like
vince was somehow connected finally
after like 35 minutes we see sydney
prescott she's a runner now which seems
like a reasonable hobby after a lifetime
of being chased by psychopaths and she
finally owns a cell phone she never had
one in scree form but seeing as how that
didn't prevent her from being targeted
by the next ghost face she probably
decided to just cave in and get one
dewey mentions that she's married to
someone named mark there is a mark in
the scream franchise that is detective
mark kincaid the cop from scream 3 who
weirdly came back to her house and
watched movies with the trio at the end
one of the bloody disgusting articles
that i mentioned earlier addresses this
the executive producer confirms that
sydney's husband is indeed mark kincaid
i can't say this fully makes sense to me
because where was he in scree form and
where is he now and why is sydney's name
still sydney prescott i'm guessing she
still wanted to take advantage of the
notoriety of her name for her career as
an author the original scream featured a
scene known as the video store scene
where randy speculates on who the killer
might be every subsequent sequel so far
has had its own version of the video
store scene this time it's the randy
meeks memorial theater scene and mindy
the new randy fills the gang in on her
ideas about who might be guilty at one
point during the scene dewey refers to
stu mocker as a real looney tune this
might be a reference to the fact that
stu was in the 2003 movie looney tunes
back in action where he plays himself
matthew lillard arguing with shaggy also
voiced by lillard about the quality of
his performance in scooby-doo the movie
a scene probably meta enough to be in a
scream movie if we're being honest in
the background there's a vertigo poster
this is now the third stream movie in a
row to reference vertigo starting with
sarah's line in scream 3 and this poster
in scree form vertigo is directed by
alfred hitchcock who borderline invented
the slasher genre with his movie psycho
psycho has been referenced in every
scream movie and that continues here
with this poster amber imitating the
psycho soundtrack as she gestures her
knife
one of the ghostface killers even
directly sights the movie this time
around never seen the movie psycho and
then we cut directly to this shot where
wes is taking a shower it's the same
camera angle used in the shower scene
from psycho and subsequently the shower
scene from stab in the second screen the
next character to die is wes as i
mentioned he gets out of the shower and
explores downstairs in the kitchen
there's a note from his mom wes lemon
squares in the fridge love mom this is a
callback to judy's famous lemon squares
which she made for dewey in scree form
sheriff
you're not cheating on your wife if you
eat my lemon square the ones that gail
found disgusting your lemon squares
taste like ass speaking of whom she
returns to the story by stepping out of
this kqis 6 news van it's the same
station that gail worked for in scream
but ever since then she's worked other
jobs such as up to date 60 minutes too
total entertainment and she even went
rogue for a while seeing her back at her
original station is exactly the choice
you'd expect from a requel looking not
to upset the status quo at this point
dewey and gail are divorced an event we
already saw brewing in scree form but it
sounds like their divorce went exactly
like their breakup in between scream 2
and scream 3. gail gets an important job
opportunity in a big city and the two
can't make it work long distance dewey
belongs in woodsboro gail belongs in a
big city reporter job once again history
seems to be repeating itself with these
two despite gail being back in her old
job the underlying theme about the media
and its effect on real world violence is
not as present in the new scream like it
was in the first four movies we do get a
little bit of discourse about the
entertainment news industry at the end
where richie seems to imply that he was
driven to the brink partly by the media
blaming fans for the poor reception of
the new stab movie but i see that as
just one aspect of a bigger conversation
around this idea of toxic fandom so what
is toxic fandom is it real is it a
problem should we be worried about it
the most agreed upon definition reads
when a person believes that they have
the only correct way of appreciating
certain content they will attack other
fans and disagree with them even when
they're discussing a topic that the
toxic fan knows little about or has only
heard from second-hand sources i will
add that it seems that toxic fandom has
also become a buzzword used by
journalists or salty creators to try to
get clicks and sway a narrative for
example let's say a new movie from a
popular franchise comes out and it's bad
those involved might soon be crying
about toxic fandom to try to make all
criticisms look invalid i'm sure there
are fans in those cases who dislike that
new movie merely because it does not fit
their belief about what the franchise
should be like but that does not make
the entire fandom toxic and it shouldn't
invalidate good criticisms based on the
quality of the work so is it a problem
should we be worried about it at the end
of the day it's all just online
discourse there's no reason to take it
that seriously i feel like it can offer
a unique perspective here as someone who
is both a fan and a creator as a fan i
try to separate my bias from my critique
for example i don't really like the
concept of toy story 4 because i think
the third was such a perfect ending but
i don't think it's a bad movie i mean i
recognize that it's well made for what
it is but when something is bad i think
it's important to be vocal about it in a
constructive way as a fan it shows that
you care and a good creator will take
quality criticism into account for
future work as a creator you have to be
able to separate good criticism from
comments by those who are never going to
like your content in the first place and
that brings us to my favorite cameo in
the movie the deadmeat cameo and this
webpage has more hidden content than you
could possibly imagine
for those unaware the couple behind the
film fells channel which richie can be
seen watching on his laptop is actually
james agenese and his wife chelsea the
host of youtube's biggest horror movie
channel deadmeat who we can actually see
a real upload from in the recommended
bar on the right it struck me as strange
that they would use a made-up brand for
their channel because this is a scream
movie all the movies and shows
referenced tend to be real movies and
shows from our world the only exception
being stab which is a stand-in for a
real franchise the scream franchise i
figured i might as well go straight to
the source on this one because i can so
i asked james why that might be this is
what he had to say mostly because we're
being a-holes in it it's a parody of
more toxic youtube channels that cover
movies it's not meant to be us or dead
memes and i think that's a great answer
because it fits right in with what i was
saying earlier about toxic fandom these
film fails characters aren't really
saying anything constructive about the
movie they're basically just pouting
that it's not the stab that they know
and are comfortable with and when i
think more about it there is actually
precedent for this sunrise studios
doesn't exist it was just a parody of a
predatory movie studio kqis6 doesn't
exist either it's a parody of
bloodthirsty journalism film fails more
specifically seems to be a parody of
youtube channels that screeched about
star wars the last jedi in 2017. judging
by that dead meat upload on the side
ryan johnson on reinventing stab ryan
johnson was the director of that heavily
debated star wars title and often the
target of vitriol from fans and content
creators i'm sure there are many people
that would like you to believe that the
last jedi was divisive or controversial
but if you actually look at the ratings
most people just found it to be very
average i already talked about
filmfail's subscriber count being wes
craven's birthday but the view count is
also significant it has 122 096 views 12
20 96 december 20th 1996 was the release
date of the original screen then there's
the like to dislike ratio it has 1 117
likes and 20 dislikes 11 17 20 or
november 17 2020 was the day that
production wrapped on scream 2022 thanks
to richie for using the return youtube
dislike extension so we could see that
one on the side there's a video from
bloody disgusting's youtube channel that
i mentioned earlier it's titled
interview with woodsboro survivor kirby
reed kirby was a major character in the
fourth movie and up until now we were
led to believe that she didn't make it
so this is actually big news the fourth
video is called not my stab join the
stab head army and hashtag redo stab
2021 and it's uploaded by a channel
called stab head there's a bit of a
story behind this one so grab some
popcorn dread it is the name of the
horror movie community on reddit mindy
actually mentions it when she's
explaining the fan content for stab aids
you go on 4chan and dread it all they're
talking about is how stab ate pissed on
their childhoods to promote scream
2022's release the team behind the movie
held an ask me anything session on
dreditz one user named stab head asked
did any of the actors go above and
beyond to prepare for their roles their
reply was we were meeting with jack to
talk about his character and he told us
that he had created a reddit account
under the name stab head to
wait a minute we love you jack quaid
necessary information jack quaid is the
actor who played richie the second
ghostface killer the account shows him
commenting on topics like halloween the
last jedi and of course scream so the
way i see it stab head is actually
richie's online persona he was the one
to create this channel and upload this
video amber even mentions during the
finale that she met richie on the stab
subreddit under the stab head upload
there's one more video of importance did
the real life stew maker survive as i
mentioned in my scream 3 video the
original plan for that movie was to have
stu return as the villain but since this
was right after columbine producers
decided it was not the best idea to have
a high school revenge seeker right now
but this video title suggests that maybe
having stu return in the future is not
yet out of the question if he's alive
then he's been in prison for about 25
years now although stu himself isn't in
this movie his actor has yet another
vocal cameo here as the voice of the new
silver-faced ghost face
one of the common complaints about the
new ghost face in stab 2021 is his new
weapon a flamethrower ironically the new
ghost face in this movie ends up getting
herself lit on fire the link to
filmfell's merch store is ostalfuego.org
spanish for until the fire which could
also be a clue about amber's fate when
she has her one last scare moment at the
end she's covered in burn scars very
reminiscent of freddy krueger you can
bet that this was by design about midway
through the film the deaths of judy and
west are discovered and sam realizes
that her sister may be in trouble at the
hospital so she gives richie a quick
call to check on her and hears an
unexpected voice on the other line
hello
samantha no
richie can't come to the phone right now
he's finding out what happens to people
who stick their noses in business that
doesn't concern them it reminds me of
jigsaw re-recording daniel matthews
voicemail greeting in saw too you've
reached daniel's phone he's not in right
now i love a good horror movie voicemail
greeting if this was the fourth movie
which had a lot of saw references this
might be an intentional mod to saw but
this is the fifth movie which focuses
more on the so-called elevated horror
genre for example tara's favorite movie
is the babadook and she begs to be
quizzed on the gems of the mid to late
tens watch me about it follows asked me
about hereditary ask me about the witch
she's got a really good taste she
describes elevated horror as being scary
but with complex emotional and thematic
underpinnings not just cheesy jump
scares which richie as a fan of stab
isn't thrilled with that sounds kind of
boring to me and in the home theater
scene stabs slasher stylings and
elevated horror are painted to be
opposites a major reason cited for fans
not liking the newest stab movie was
crammed in social commentary so richie
was upset that his favorite franchise
was trying to ride the trendy wave of
elevated horror and set out to craft his
own entry more in line with the original
by doing a request the huge gaping
question that leaves is isn't that
exactly what jill already tried to do
and yes it is the only difference was
their motivations jill did it for fame
but richie and amber just wanted to
motivate the creation of another stab
movie it doesn't seem like being the
star was as important to them even if we
are to give them the benefit of the
doubt and say that these killers are an
homage to scream for rather than copying
it there are still a couple of other
necessary details to make it make sense
which i didn't fully realize in my first
view the first is that there is no stab
movie based on scree form if there was
richie and amber probably wouldn't have
felt the need to make a new one at the
time of screeform there are seven stab
movies and in this movie there's only
one new one hence the hashtag redo stab
8. then there's the fact that the
original scream and really all of the
stream movies do feature some kind of
social commentary which i've taken time
to discuss in each of my things you miss
videos so why would richie be upset
about the newstab having social
commentary this is because in the scream
universe the stab movies are considered
non-fiction nobody is making up the plot
so nothing that happens qualifies as
commentary because that's how you make a
great stab movie sam
based on actual events and this ties
right back into the theme of toxic
fandom richie believes that each stab
movie must be like the original that's
why there's so many repeated elements
from the original screen like when tara
is trying to defend herself at the
hospital
oh
god damn it
must have been thrilling for richie to
be reliving events from the original
stab you've gotta find me
in some cases lines are nearly lifted
directly from a previous movie you think
you're still the star this isn't a
[ __ ] movie it will
be this is a
movie
no
but it will be the final act features
plenty more references some of which you
might have noticed but you probably
missed this tiny detail which was the
reason that mindy was able to survive
where others did not
welcome to act 3.
[Music]
before we get to the final act let's
talk about dewey his fatal mistake is
shooting amber's bulletproof armor
rather than hitting her in the head he
realizes it a little too late in scream
3 he makes the same mistake with roman
but sydney is there to remind him to aim
for the head this time she isn't and
dewey pays the price given dewey's
ability to survive seemingly fatal blows
in the past i wasn't convinced that he
was really done for this time we've seen
this scene before however the more i
look at it the more i think he might
really be gone this time he's being
taken to the coroner this time not the
ambulance i doubt the coroner would be
called unless some medical professional
was really sure that he was dead dewey
had to die to make it real to show that
this wasn't just some [ __ ]
cash in run-of-the-mill sequel well this
is awkward it also fits the blueprint of
a requel when the cast is talking about
request mindy brings up star wars the
force awakens as an example there will
be spoilers for star wars the force
awakens here so if you don't want to
hear them skip forward to the next
chapter the force awakens is all about
passing the torch to a new set of
characters luke leia and han are passing
it off to rey finn and poe this is
accentuated by the death of a legacy
character han solo so scream 2022 is
doing the same here by killing off dewey
as the torch has passed from sydney
dewey and gayle to sam tara mindy and
chad and just as the force awakens
brought back familiar locations like the
millennium falcon and the starkiller
which is basically the death star scream
2022 brings back the mocker household
which plays host to another party which
is probably the most tasteless thing
ever considering it's supposedly
supposed to honor their friend wes but
it looks like a typical college party i
guess it's kind of fitting though
considering the existence of this movie
here we see a few more call backs the
basement fridge is the new garage fridge
many people have basements in california
richie is wearing a blue plaid shirt
like former woodsboro killers billy
loomis and jill roberts when sydney
arrives the first door she checks behind
is the same one she hid behind when she
donned the ghostface mask in the
original screen perhaps the most obvious
repeat is the infamous look behind you
scene which we've seen play out in
various forms across most scream movies
mindy is the new randy so fittingly
she's the one being snuck up on but
unlike randy she realizes it and
attempts to get out of the way this is
partially because she knows she's in a
movie and she might be a little bit
sharper than randy but there's also an
important clue in stab there are a
couple of vhs tapes on the table behind
stab randy i think the top one might be
the people under the stairs another wes
craven reference and i'm having a hard
time making out what the bottom one is
let me know if you recognize it but look
directly below the tv she's watching on
and you'll see three vhs tapes two of
which are the same two on the table
behind randy there's a slightly better
look at it later when sam is tending to
mindy's injuries it's definitely the
same two tapes mindy by the way does
survive which could be related to this
little line from scree form in fact the
only surefire way to survive a modern
horror movie
you pretty much have to be gay it also
helps to be the daughter of a serial
killer as it turns out she may be
related to billy loomis but sam wipes
her knife off a lot more like stewmacher
now before i get into the ending and my
views on what this really means for the
franchise i've got to go over all of the
evidence seen throughout the film that
proves who the killers really were as i
have at the end of each of my scream
analysis videos so let's take it back
one more time to the start in the
opening tara invites amber to come over
mentioning that her mom was out of town
amber and richie were probably waiting
for an opportunity like this and used it
to decide that this would be the night
that they strike when tara starts
receiving concerning phone calls she
gets a text from amber which says you
should answer it the caller explains
that amber's phone was cloned and no one
really questions it but the easier and
correct explanation is that amber was
just the killer using her own phone when
sam gets a ghostface call in the
hospital it's also from amber's phone
amber and richie have to act like
they're meeting for the first time we
see her look at him very lustfully which
makes more sense now knowing that they
were secretly a couple sam is attacked
at the hospital at the same time that
amber was being questioned by hicks the
police station which means this one must
have been richie this is the same old
trick used to get billy loomis off the
hook and scream and get roman off the
hook in scream 3. when are they gonna
learn that there are always multiple
killers then there's the scene where
dewey correctly predicts a killer by
accusing richie this is just like randy
in the original scream his first guess
is billy and it's correct he's got
killer printed all over his fart the
most damning evidence comes after he
kicks richie and sam out though listen
to what richie has to say about him
jesus
yeah he's way more fun in the movies
notice the plural use of the word movies
at this point in the story he claims
that he's only seen one stab movie the
original when he and sam were driving to
woodsboro he claimed to have no idea
about the stab movies and then at the
hospital he says he's watching the first
one on netflix so he can be prepared
lucky for him sam doesn't seem to notice
the slip up while it's not necessarily
evidence i do think the fact that he
spends his spare time watching vitriol
about stab 2021 is kind of telling about
where his interests lie even if his
reasoning is that he's trying to learn
about the franchise later on during the
second attack at the hospital amber cuts
richie in the forearm we saw this in
scree form where jill was cut in the
same spot by her fellow accomplice as a
way to deflect suspicion away from her
in my previous video i labeled this as a
nod to scream 2 where derek is cut in
the forearm and dewey finds it
suspicious because the cut conveniently
missed any major arteries despite some
of the well-hidden evidence that i
mentioned i found these killers to be
pretty obvious perhaps the fact that
they are so similar to the killers from
the last movie made them stand out a
little bit more we close with the same
pull out shot of a news anchor giving a
report in front of the house but this
time it is not gayle weathers like the
main characters and the filmmakers the
news anchor microphone has been passed
down to the next generation at the end
over the dedication to the series late
former director we hear a bird call
it links back to all of the bird artwork
seen in amber's house it's all part of
one last tribute to scream's iconic
director wes craven who in his spare
time was an avid bird watcher the sound
at the end of scream 2022 is the call of
the whipperwell a sound effect that
kraven has actually used a few times in
his films in this 2008 interview in the
bird enthusiast magazine audubon he
explains how he has used bird sounds as
sort of an orchestration in his work
i've used the whipper wheel a few times
probably inappropriately but it's such a
haunting sound and i do remember the
sound from being a kid in the woods of
ohio and on camping trips but yeah i
think they're used a lot in hollywood i
would be the first to confess that
accuracy is probably not the first
motivation we get a quick flash of
somebody in a ghostface mask wiping off
a knife before the credits roll maybe an
homage to the quick scares seen before
the credits of scream
and in scream 2.
no such scare occurs in scream 3 or four
to me the implication is that seeing a
new ghost face right before the end
credits is teasing a sequel we don't see
it in three because roman is defeated
and for now that means the end of the
series while scream 4 was not planned to
be the final movie it was the end of
that era of scream and there's nothing
in the story that prevents the fourth
movie from being the final chapter
unlike scream one which specifically has
a line about how there's gotta be a
sequel and stream two which specifically
has a line suggesting that it's a
trilogy so the quick flash of ghostface
at the end of scream 2022 to me is the
director's way of telling us that they
planned for a sequel and with a sixth
movie being given the go-ahead before
the fifth was even globally released it
seems likely the next chapter was
planned and it'll tie in nicely with the
material in the 2022 offering if you're
excited for scream six you're in the
right place because i'll be covering it
here on this channel when it comes out
so make sure you subscribe to cz's world
for new horrors every week ring the
death bell and select all notifications
so you don't miss anything and i will
see you in the next one assuming we both
survive
[Music]